en moins d'une semaine la mobilisation
donne un premier résultat leur combat
est relayé par les médias locaux ça
c'était le premier article qui est paru
juste après l'enlèvement donc du jour
après un lèvement
la volonté c'était vraiment ça on parle
de Jena et Barry pour que
quelqu'un se sente obligé d'intervenir
et que voilà on comprenne que la
situation
était en plus inquiétante pour eux
c'est sans doute l'une des plus grandes
peurs de tout parents
qu'un jour subitement son enfant
disparaisse
Marie-Laure ne vit plus qu'au ralenti
depuis que ces deux enfants ont été
enlevés
[Musique]
depuis 15 ans Jonathan a mis sa vie
entre parenthèses
depuis le jour où sa fille a disparu
il attend de la revoir ou au moins
d'obtenir des nouvelles
ou quand comment pourquoi leur quotidien
est rythmé par ces questions qu'il est
hante même si une seule compte vraiment
reverront-il un jour leurs enfants
je m'appelle Jonathan Oliver je suis le
père d'une fille qui a disparu il y a 15
ans
je m'appelle Marie-Laure je suis la
maman de deux enfants disparu depuis
plus de 2 ans
Jonathan Marie-Laure un père une mère un
jour du printemps 1997 Cécile Vallin la
fille de Jonathan a disparu pour
Marie-Laure Fazio le drame est survenu
en 2010 lorsque son ancien compagnon est
parti avec leurs enfants Jena et Barry
aujourd'hui l'un et l'autre navigue
entre l'incertitude et le folle espoir
de revoir un jour leurs enfants
[Musique]
ça c'est la photo de Cécile que j'ai
prise d'elle quand on était en vacances
en Bretagne cette photo cela fait 15 ans
qu'elle est posée sur l'étagère
15 ans que cet anglais n'a pas vu sa
fille sa petite dernière
alors de temps en temps il aime bien se
plonger dans ses souvenirs
[Musique]
et très aimé de son papa aussi
aujourd'hui Jonathan survit
hanté par cette question
qu'est-il arrivé à sa fille
[Musique]
tout commence le 8 juin 1997 à l'époque
jonathan est séparé de la mère de Cécile
depuis 10 ans il vit en Normandie mais
Cécile elle vit avec sa mère en Savoie à
900 km de là malgré cette distance
géographique le père et la fille sont
très proches ce 8 juin Cécile l'appel
d'ailleurs pour lui raconter une fête
qu'elle a organisé c'est la dernière
fois qu'il se parleront
cet après-midi là elle m'a appelée
c'était une conversation courte ou
justement elle me parlait d'avoir fait
cette petite fête avec quelques amis la
maison
et je lui dis bah tu ferais mieux de
préparer ton baccalauréat qui était la
semaine d'après
ces derniers mots c'était justement je
vais m'y mettre
vers 17h Cécile raccroche et qu'ils sont
domicile Cécile ne part pas de chez elle
avec l'intention d'aller quelque part
elle n'a pas de sac elle n'a pas de
papier elle est légèrement vêtue il fait
beau voilà ça se ça ressemble à une
promenade en fin d'après-midi et les
vues par plusieurs personnes et mais à
partir de 18h 18h30
personne ne l'a vu
deux jours plus tard lorsque sa mère et
son beau-père rentre de week-end il se
rendent compte que Cécile est absente et
qu'elle est injoignable tout de suite il
prévienne les gendarmes
et donc quand moi j'ai appelé le
lendemain j'ai la mère de Cécile au
téléphone qui m'annonce que Cécile n'est
pas rentré
et une Safa où elle est
et que les gendarmes sont dans la maison
alors pour moi j'ai eu un sentiment
de
d'angoisse d'inquiétude
de peur
absolue je me suis dit tout de suite
le pire est arrivé
pour Jonathan qui vit si loin cette
absence est plus qu'inquiétante car il
n'est jamais resté si longtemps sans
nouvelles de sa fille il est en état de
choc il ne comprend pas
de rien
ne me préparait pour cette
disparition brutale
c'est un enfant sans histoire ni déprimé
ni rebelle
absolument pas le profil
d'une fugueuse Cécile Valin n'est pas
une adolescente en rébellion elle
n'avait aucune raison de fuguer Jonathan
se rend immédiatement à Grenoble la
grande ville la plus proche de
Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne
et avait quelqu'un qui pensait que
Cécile pouvait être à Grenoble grande
ville qui est pas très loin
et donc on a passé le week-end un
placardé la ville de d'affiche
[Musique]
il n'y a rien de tangible il y a rien de
rassurant qui ne ressort de cette
distribution de tracts c'est affiche
collée
sur les murs sur les arrêts de bus ça ne
donne aucun résultat Jonathan retourne
alors chez lui en Normandie heureusement
il n'est pas seul il est soutenu par
Jacques et Mireille ses amis et voisins
ils connaissent bien Cécile et pour eux
aussi sa disparition est inquiétante
c'est pas du tout le genre de fille à
partir à fuguer
donc il y avait quelque chose à normal
il y avait pas de coup de fil il y avait
pas eu de voilà elle avait des rapports
extrêmement forts avec son père et
qu'elle n'ait pas appelée pendant ces
trois jours là un peu étonné quoi trois
jours
le délai que se donne les gendarmes pour
riches deviennent beaucoup plus active
donc il y a eu un rassemblement d'une
équipe importante d'une vingtaine de
personnes
hélicoptère pour survoler les lieux
hommes grenouille pour fouiller dans les
lacs c'est montagneux il y a beaucoup de
cours d'eau et de lacs
Messenger rien du tout
[Musique]
en général qu'elle soit vivante ou
décédée on retrouve la personne disparue
dans les jours qui suivent dans le cas
de Cécile après trois semaines et en
dépit des moyens mis en oeuvre elle
reste introuvable
les forces de l'ordre et les proches de
la jeune femme ne se décourage pas pour
autant
dès qu'il y avait un indice à une forme
de quelqu'un qui pensait peut-être
l'avoir reconnu à la terrasse d'un café
ou dans une ville où y aller on sautait
dessus quoi vraiment tout de suite bon
et puis ça s'estompe il y a plus de
coups de fil il y a plus de traces il y
a plus d'indice et donc on est moins sur
la brèche je dirais quoi et c'est ça
aussi qui se dilue et on est plus dans
dans savoir ce qui s'est passé que dans
dire elle va nous appeler demain matin
quoi alors que les premiers temps on
attendait un coup de fil une carte
postale quelque chose parce qu'il y a
jamais rien eu jamais jamais
en dépit du manque d'indice Jonathan
refuse d'envisager le pire il veut
garder espoir
[Musique]
votre nom a malheureusement été
médiatisé en 2003 lorsque votre fille
Estelle
âgée de 9 ans à l'époque a disparu vous
écrivez à ce propos je me souviens très
exactement de ce que j'ai ressenti
l'impression que ma colonne vertébrale
venait de se transformer en abloc de
glace et immédiatement c'est évident
Estelle a été enlevé on imagine mal les
premières heures les premiers jours
après la disparition d'un enfant
qu'est-ce qu'on a en tête je crois que
ça fait c'est une des questions à
laquelle je n'arrive pas à répondre
depuis 10 ans et que je n'arrive pas à
expliquer justement quand on me pose
cette question justement de d'expliquer
ce qui se passe le vide dans lequel on
est
la rafale de questions que l'on se pose
le doute qui s'installe surtout on se
demande qui a pu faire ça et en passant
en revue tous les gens qu'on connaît
tous ceux qu'on connaît pas on imagine
tout à construire des scénarios tous
plus improbables les uns que les autres
et en fait on est face au vide puisqu'il
n'y a pas de réponse et en même temps
on devient acteur de quelque chose qui
nous dépasse complètement donc
je n'arrive pas à expliquer ce qui se
passe ce qui s'est passé en tout cas
dans ma tête est-ce qu'il y a dû se
passer dans la tête des autres je sais
quelque chose que je ne sais
malheureusement pas exprimer
correctement mais c'est un petit peu
peut-être la sensation du plongeon qu'on
a quand on est enfant et qu'on va au
plongeon de s'y mettre au plongeon de 6
mètres et au moment où on se jette on
sait pas ce qu'on va trouver et on est
dans cette situation là vous dites
également dans votre livre qu'accrocher
soi-même des affiches pour son enfant
c'est une très mauvaise idée pourquoi
dans un premier temps c'est la très
bonne idée puisque ça permet d'être dans
l'action et de on a l'impression de
prendre les choses en main de mobiliser
les énergies d'être efficace et bien sûr
plus on va être efficace et plus on va
en faire et plus on va y arriver donc on
en fait beaucoup et on en fait sans
doute trop c'est après qu'on réalise ce
que ça veut dire
d'avoir collé des avis de recherche de
son enfant paraître un peu une image
choquante mais moi c'est quand je vois
les affiches perdus le petit chat tigré
ou le petit chien machin le chihuahua
je me dis que les affiches de sel ont
peut-être été perçues comme les affiches
de recherche des petits chats
jusqu'ici les recherches pour retrouver
ces sylvalin n'ont rien donné mais pour
retrouver sa fille Jonathan Oliver va
tout tenter y compris les méthodes les
moins conventionnelles
[Musique]
Marie-Laure Fazio et la mère de deux
enfants de 9 et 7 ans Jenna et Barry
elle ne les a pas vu depuis plus de deux
ans
je dors ici voilà
en face de la photo de mes enfants et de
des peluches avec lesquels ils dormaient
je mets pas trop de photos parce que
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
sur les photos ils étaient un peu figées
et j'ai envie de les vivre en moi plus
que sur les photos
Marie-Laure n'a gardé que très peu
d'affaires de ses enfants c'est leur
deux derniers dessins de la gare de riz
et c'est moi
voilà puis se par ma fille et puis par
mon fils à droite voilà
c'est leur maman donc
quel est le sourire j'espère qu'elle
retrouvera
le drame commence en 2010 à l'époque
Marie-Laure est séparée depuis 5 ans du
père de ses enfants Hakim Seba dès 2006
alors que les parents ont la garde
alternée Hakim part avec les petits une
première fois
dépassée par la gestion de deux enfants
en bas âge il finira par les ramener
conséquence il perd leur garde la seule
façon pour lui de voir Jenna et Barry
c'est alors au sein d'une association de
médiation familiale
c'est lors d'une de ses visites que
quatre ans plus tard la vie de
Marie-Laure va basculer
alors le 4 avril je dépose mes enfants à
l'association Trait d'Union je les
dépose à 10h du matin j'ai déjà un
mauvais pressentiment puisque je ne vois
pas la voiture du père devant garer
devant la situation donc je vais quand
même rentrer à la maison et toute la
journée je vais avoir cette boule au
ventre en me disant ce que je n'aurais
pas dû attendre et le suivre finalement
à 17h je vais chercher mes enfants et
n'y sont pas le père des a pas ramenés
[Musique]
là tous s'effondre en fait mes jambes
j'ai l'impression que mes jambes ne me
portent plus
voilà je
suis entre le la peur et je pleure et
mes enfants quoi ils sont plus là j'en
ai déjà la certitude ils sont déjà loin
pour moi
Marie-Laure se ressaisit et se rend
aussitôt à la gendarmerie
et les gendarmes ne vont pas perdre de
temps c'est vraiment ils ont été
vraiment très réactifs c'est à dire que
à 17h30 on a la gendarmerie les enfants
sont déjà et le père et déjà signalé sur
le personne sur le fichier des personnes
recherchées
où se trouve Hakim l'ex-compagnon de
Marie-Laure où son mari et Jenna
deux jours plus tard une information
judiciaire est ouverte elle permet de
découvrir de premiers indices
on va analyser son téléphone et on va se
rendre compte que à 10h30 il est déjà
voilà qui en quittant l'association elle
est déjà sur la route de Marseille le
port de Marseille c'est la zone de
transit pour se rendre vers le Maghreb
Marie-Laure comprend aussitôt kaki mais
en France mais originaire d'Algérie a
emmené ses enfants là-bas tout le monde
a la certitude à ce moment-là qu'il est
en Algérie mais on n'a pas le moyen de
le prouver à qui Mathilde traversé la
Méditerranée avec Jenna et Barry un seul
moyen de le savoir faire parler ses
proches assez rapidement donc la famille
a été interrogée pour le chercher au
départ tout simplement et pour avoir des
traces de son départ un billet d'avion
quelque chose sur Internet une
réservation
et c'est la famille qui va qui va
clairement dire voilà il est parti au
bled et de là
on pourra déclencher je crois que ça a
été le 24 avril le mandataire
international est arrivé très vite le 24
avril donc
le fait qu'il soit recherché dans le
monde entier
cela fait trois semaines que ses enfants
ont disparu lorsque Marie-Laure apprend
une très mauvaise nouvelle
parce que je sais pas au moment de
l'émission du mandat de la réassage je
ne sais pas encore que l'Algérie ne
l'applique pas puisque l'Algérie
n'extradit pas c'est ressortissant tout
comme la France c'est à dire malgré
qu'il y a mandat d'arrêt international
il ne s'applique pas dans le pays du
ressortissant le mandataire
international pour l'instant il a servi
absolument à rien
[Musique]
vous êtes avocate la situation dans
laquelle se trouve Marie-Laure semblait
être un vrai casse-tête juridique on
peut s'étonner que l'Algérie n'extrate
pas ses ressortissants mais la France ne
le fait pas non plus
ça signifie que une situation inverse
est possible en effet la situation
inverse est possible nous n’extradons
pas l'Algérie in extrate pas c'est une
question de convention entre les pays et
effectivement je dirais des Français qui
enlèveraient un enfant dans ce cadre
parental ne serait pas extradé non plus
comment expliquer qu'aucune juridiction
internationale depuis cette ressaisie en
réalité cette juridiction n'existe pas
puisque elle serait supranationale et
elle serait mondiale ce qui est
impossible chaque état a le droit
d'avoir je dirais ces législations et sa
justice et c'est les décisions internes
à ce pays qui doivent être appliqués au
respectées il existe des conventions
entre plusieurs pays n'existe pas
d'intervention je dirais de d'office
judiciaire international qui imposerait
au pays des décisions de ce type là
elles ont tous les cas pas été créé à ce
jour elle serait difficile à imposer un
certain nombre de pays donc ça n'est on
ne peut fonctionner que sur des
conventions entre plusieurs pays
ses enfants en Algérie son ex compagnon
introuvable Marie-Laure Fazio est seul
face à une situation qu'il a dépasse
témoin de sa détresse son entourage
décide de l'aider en créant
l'association Jenna et Barry et si mes
amis qui ont une voix décidée me tenir
qui vont me soutenir et
qui vont décider de créer cette
association qui va venir en soutien au
début pour une mobilisation c'est à dire
pour pour dire on est nombreux et on va
se battre pour le retour de djenebari
une association a été créée peu de temps
après la l'enlèvement des enfants
c'était surtout pour faire connaître
leur histoire et puis permettre de
soutenir Marie-Laure notamment
financièrement puisque ça impliqué dans
le monde frais de justice de frais
d'avocat c'est un soutien moral c'est un
soutien financier en fait c'est toute
une équipe qui est autour d'elle en
moins d'une semaine la mobilisation
donne un premier résultat leur combat
est relayé par les médias locaux ça
c'était le premier article qui est paru
juste après l'enlèvement donc 10 jours
après un lavement
la volonté c'était vraiment ça qu'on
parle de Jenna et Barry pour que
quelqu'un se sente obligé d'intervenir
et que voilà on comprenne que la
situation
était en plus inquiétante pour eux
et la médiatisation va si bien
fonctionner qu'on va entendre parler de
Jenna et Barry jusqu'au sommet de l'État
[Musique]
l'été qui suit la disparition de Cécile
Vallin ses proches consacrent tous leurs
temps à diffuser son image
à cette époque très peu de gens
utilisent Internet alors tous les moyens
sont bons pour que le visage de Cécile
dépasse les frontières de la Savoie
notre premier idée c'est diffuser
les affiches avec l'image de ces cils un
petit descriptif et le numéro de
téléphone d'urgence 24 heures sur 24 et
on choisit Paris et notamment les gares
parce que c'est les lieux de convergence
des gens qui viennent de partout en
France on fait des t-shirts pour qu'on
voit l'image de Cécile et qu'on voit le
numéro de téléphone d'urgence pour
centraliser les aides une association
est créée elle porte son prénom Cécile
elle rassemble notamment les proches de
Jonathan
Mireille sa voisine en devient la
vice-présidente
Cécile mesure 1m65 et de type européen
son visage é ovale fin régulier sa peau
et mat ses yeux en amont de couleur
noisettes tirent sur le verre on a
choisi deux photos de Cécile en fait une
avec les cheveux courts deux ou trois
mois avant
sa disparition et une un peu plus
ancienne mais où elle avait les cheveux
relevés en chignon donc il y a aussi eu
les macarons qu'on distribué à l'entrée
des autoroutes pour que les gens
puissent les mettre sur leur voiture
c'était important de communiquer on
n'avait pas forcément l'expérience de la
communication et voilà les idées de
chacun et étaient vraiment bienvenue et
ça nous a permis d'échanger c'est le
moment très très fort et moment très
très fort
en étant convaincu en fait qu'on la
retrouverait rapidement
à l'époque les méthodes sont encore
artisanales
qui a été mise en place le dispositif
alerte enlèvement
vous êtes commissaire du visionnaire
vous dirigez le crvp l'Office central de
la répression des violences aux
personnes alors il y a un élément qui a
changé beaucoup de choses c'est le
dispositif Alerte Enlèvement quels sont
les critères qui vous poussent à le
déclencher donc quatre critères doivent
être réunis de manière cumulative pour
déclencher le plan donc déjà que ce soit
mineur l'enfant
il faut que on soit certains qu'il est
victime d'un enlèvement pas une simple
disparition
il faut que ça vie soit en danger vous
savez ou soit l'intégrité physique
et quatrième critère il faut également
que les enquêteurs disposent d'éléments
dont la diffusion au public soit de
nature à apporter les témoignages on dit
que les premières heures sont
primordiales dans le cas de disparition
d'enfants pourquoi en fait je pense
qu'il y a deux types de raisons qui
peuvent expliquer cette
analyse la première résulte statistiques
américaines au terme desquels 92% des
enfants enlevés sont tués dans les 24
premières heures 92% c'est énorme ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut donc être très
réactif pour essayer de d'avoir l'espoir
de sauver un enfant sauver une vie la
deuxième raison c'est que effectivement
très rapidement le ravisseur plus plus
le temps va passer plus il y a des
risques
qui s'éloignent du lieu de la
disparition et plus il va s'éloigner
plus il va prendre de l'avance sur les
services d'enquête plus il a les risques
de d'échapper aux mailles du filet
en juillet 1997 Alerte Enlèvement
n'existe pas alors à moi après la
disparition de ces cils ses proches vont
utiliser des moyens peu conventionnels
en juillet 97 donc un mois après la
disparition de Cécile
je suis à Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne avec
la maman de Cécile qui
[Musique]
est en relation avec
médium
qui
est à la certitude que Cécile est à La
Rochelle Jonathan et sceptique mais à ce
stade aucune piste ne doit être négligée
[Musique]
j'y vais et arriver là-bas on m'a dit on
me dit voilà elle est su elle marche sur
la plage
sur une presqu'île à côté de la Rochette
donc je me rends sur le presqu'île ceci
n'était pas là et je ne suis pas étonné
je ne suis pas étonné
malgré l'association malgré toutes les
tentatives de ses proches aucune piste
n'aboutit
Cécile reste introuvable les mois
passent et Jonathan doit affronter
l'absence et le doute une épreuve qu'il
faut pourtant accepter il a fait avec
quoi il a fait ou il a continué sa vie
il a continué à travailler la continuer
à avoir des relations il a continué à
vivre quoi bon tout en ayant cette
histoire là en lui il y pense
[Musique]
croit qu'il est convaincu que Cécile va
revenir
je crois qu'il peut pas penser autrement
[Musique]
mais Jonathan sait que dans sa situation
le temps est un ennemi cruel
c'était quelque chose que je redoute
c'est le passage du temps sans le savoir
d'abord c'était les heures les jours les
semaines
des mois
et
maintenant ce sont les années
ça c'est pénible
[Musique]
malgré tous les dispositifs mis en
oeuvre 11 longues années vont passer
avant qu'il y ait du nouveau dans
l'enquête sur la disparition de sa fille
Cécile Valla
11 ans avant qu'en fin cette affaire
connaissent un nouvel élément
[Musique]
du côté de Marie-Laure le mandat d'arrêt
international contre son ex-conjoint ne
donne rien
puisque la voie judiciaire est une
impasse elle décide de viser plus haut
et je comprends rapidement que si la
diplomatie ne s'emmêle pas
les enfants ne reviendront pas
donc rapidement je vais je vais
contacter
l'Élysée le Premier ministre ministre
des affaires étrangères de la justice
enfin tous les tous les ministères
concernés en tout cas par ce genre de
problème je vais écrire et je vais
expliquer la situation
au début j'ai pas de contact direct avec
l'État français donc je vais envoyer
massivement des courriers et je vais
envoyer beaucoup de mails sur la boîte
de lycée et je vais faire ça beaucoup la
nuit en fait parce que ça va très très
mal j'ai beaucoup de mal à dormir à ce
moment-là et donc je vais vraiment
essayer de les faire réagir et de leur
dire voilà c'est juste inadmissible en
fait de quel pays nous dise voilà
maintenant on peut pas s'agir dans les
affaires judiciaires d'un autre pays
alors que finalement vous voilà vous
avez conçu deux enfants en France qui
sont nés en France leur père est né en
France je suis né en France je suis
ressortie sans français et la France
vous dit mais je peux on peut plus rien
pour vous et
mes enfants en fait tout le monde s'en
fout
Marie-Laure se sent abandonné elle a
l'impression que pendant de longs mois
son sort n'intéresse personne
jusqu'à l'automne 2011 lorsqu'elle finit
par être entendue par le Président de la
République de l'époque
[Musique]
le 14 novembre 2011 on va recevoir une
lettre de Nicolas Sarkozy donc signé
pour la première fois de sa main qui dit
que il va directement saisir monsieur
Bouteflika donc le président de
l'Algérie pour lui demander un retour
des enfants et à ce que je vois les
enfants
enfin je viens de saisir personnellement
le président Bouteflika
mon engagement à vos côtés pour y
parvenir et total
malheureusement malgré cette apparente
compassion les mots de Nicolas Sarkozy
ne changeront rien ce ne sera pas suivi
des faits parce que je n'ai toujours pas
vu mes enfants et j'ai eu beaucoup
d'espoir à ce moment-là beaucoup
beaucoup
c'est devenu une affaire politique on
n'est pas dans une histoire de garde
d'enfant c'est devenu la France et
l'Algérie qui ont des rapports
conflictuels et qui ne veulent pas
reconnaître une décision de justice qui
a été prise en France tout simplement
donc finalement mes enfants
le père la mère je veux dire on en parle
pas on parle de des relations
bilatérales entre la France et l'Algérie
et après on vient me dire mais c'est
plus finalement votre problème on
débrouillez-vous mais je peux pas me
débrouiller face à ça je peux pas me
débrouiller face à au conflit ou à la
bonne entente de donation ça ça me
dépasse complètement puisque l'État
français ne lui ramène pas ses enfants
Marie-Laure décide de se rendre en
Algérie elle souhaite utiliser ce qu'on
appelle une procédure d'exéquatture il
s'agit de faire appliquer en Algérie un
jugement déjà rendu en France
une solution idéale pour lui permettre
de récupérer ses enfants seulement il y
a un problème
alors sachant d'après les éléments du
dossier que la relation entre les deux
parties n'est pas considérée comme un
mariage au sens de la loi algérienne
c'était une relation de concubinage ce
qui rend cette relation illégale et
contraire au principe fondamentaux de
l'État algérien ce qui conclut au rejet
de la demande autrement dit puisqu'il
n'était pas marié Marie-Laure n'a pas
plus de droits sur ses enfants que son
ex-compagnon
j'ai péché
par contre mes par contre c'est pas
grave
malgré cette échec Marie-Laure veut
utiliser ce voyage en Algérie pour au
moins voir quelques instants ses enfants
[Musique]
je vais aller voir le procureur je vais
aller voir
le président du tribunal de Béjaïa donc
la ville où ils sont enfin oui
très possible qu'il soit pour demander
de les voir à l'amiable en fait je leur
demande de contacter le père pour pour
que je puisse voir mes enfants je
n'aurais jamais aucune réponse
pas de réponse et pourtant Marie-Laure
insiste et revient vite sur place
pour mon deuxième voyage je sais où sont
les enfants donc je vais me rendre à
l'école de mes enfants en fait pour
essayer de les voir et malheureusement
ça va ça va être préjudiciable puisque
puisque la directrice va en informer le
père et que ils seront par la suite
déplacés donc je vais pas pouvoir les
voir
et finalement bon je rentre assez abattu
je suis complètement perdue
le découragement get Marie-Laure et
pourtant elle ne peut pas abandonner
l'idée de retrouver ses enfants
j'ai toujours vécu avec mes enfants donc
j'ai toujours vécu pour eux et avec eux
finalement donc je me retrouve sans eux
donc ce qui est une douleur voilà
descriptible je pense qu'il y a pas de
mots et voilà j'essaie de douleur là qui
me qui m'empêcher de respirer que je
suis phoque et mon corps suffoque tout
de ma tête enfin je veux dire tout il y
a plus rien qui qui n'a de sens et en
plus je me retrouve là de voir vivre
sans savoir quoi faire et pourquoi en
fait
cette situation est d'autant plus
difficile à vivre que Marie-Laure se
sent trahi par l'homme qu'elle a aimé
[Musique]
moi j'ai rencontré quelqu'un donc le
père de mes enfants c'était l'homme
idéal pour moi enfin en tout cas pour
voilà pour une famille pour
il était doux il était gentil il était à
l'écoute je sais pas rencontré
l'individu qui est enlevé mes enfants en
fait et c'est difficile de faire
comprendre aux gens que vous n'êtes pas
volontairement traîner une situation
comme ça vous n'êtes pas mis avec la
pire des crapules pour vivre un truc
parce que vous étiez en manque de
sensation dans votre vie moi jamais
j'aurais pu imaginer ça déjà parce qu'il
avait pas de lien avec l'Algérie à ce
moment-là du tout il ne parlait pas la
langue et il avait un discours tout à
fait ouvert c'est à dire que n'a jamais
essayé de m'imposer quoi que ce soit
donc un discours qui est complètement
contradiction avec ses actes aujourd'hui
et ça c'est important parce que je on a
toujours l'impression finalement il y a
beaucoup de jugements là dessus de
personnes qui se disent oui mais bon
elle savait elle a finalement ce qu'elle
mérite mais c'est c'est complètement
faux
Marie-Laure ne reconnaît plus l'homme
qu'elle a aimé et surtout elle craint
que celui-ci ne manipule ses deux
enfants pour les éloigner d'elle ce
syndrome a un nom les psychiatres
l'appellent l'aliénation parentale
vous êtes psychiatre ce que l'on appelle
l'aliénation parentale vous pouvez nous
dire ce que c'est l'aliénation parentale
je dirais que c'est un rap psychique
l'enfant est là physiquement mais il
devient progressivement ou subitement ça
dépend des cas une sorte d’étranger et
là vraiment on a aussi une sorte deuil
d'un enfant en vie auquel vous n'avez
plus accès et vous ne le reconnaissez
pas donc dans aliénée il y a deux mots
il y a le côté de rendre étranger ou au
style alien c'est un étranger et puis
c'est le a privatif couper le lien vous
aviez un lien il était de bonne qualité
et vous n'en avez plus et alors dans le
cas de Marie-Laure est-ce qu'il y a un
risque d'aliénation parentale alors si
on prend aliénation au sens étymologique
rupture du lien il y a un risque mais
c'est pas exactement ce concept
n'oublions pas ce concept c'est le rejet
par un enfant là c'est un enfant qu'on
prive physiquement de sa mère et le
risque c'est celui de l'amnésie
infantile
le père a carte blanche pour dire que ce
qu'il veut effectivement et de surcroît
l'enfant peut avoir son amnésie un
enfant de 5 ans aura très très peu de
souvenirs de sa mère s'il la revoit
l'adolescence et c'est là que je veux
croire en tant que psychiatre à la force
de l'empreinte si Marie-Laure a eu avec
ses enfants un lien aussi fort et aussi
affectif qu'elle le dit je veux croire
qu'on peut rester optimiste et que la
mémoire affective sera plus fort que la
mémoire intellectuelle
pour éviter qu'une telle situation ne se
produise il est impératif que
Marie-Laure retrouve ses enfants au plus
vite
elle sait que le chemin risque d'être
long mais elle espère beaucoup de
l'élection de François Hollande
[Musique]
en Normandie chez Jonathan les années
ont défilé sans rien apporter de concret
au dossier 11 ans que Cécile a disparu
11 ans sans aucune piste sérieuse
jusqu'à ce mois de mai 2008 ou une
avancée technologique importante et mise
à la disposition des enquêteurs
l'espoir de trouver une trace de Cécile
est alors si grand qu'il est repris dans
les journaux télévisés
[Musique]
il y a 11 ans disparaissait en Savoie
c'est sylvalin une jeune fille de 17 ans
elle avait été vue pour la dernière fois
marchant le long d'une route
départementale en direction de Chambéry
aujourd'hui de nouvelles recherches ont
été lancées sur la 43 pour tenter de
retrouver son corps le géoradar il
permet grâce à des ondes
électromagnétiques de détecter jusqu'à 2
mètres de profondeur les anomalies dans
n'importe quel sol
accompagnée de chiens spécialistes et
dans la recherche d'ossements les
experts vont ratisser les bas-côtés de
l'autoroute entre Saint-Jean et
Saint-Michel de Maurienne il se donne
trois jours mais après
après trois jours les résultats seront
négatifs
Jonathan et c'est malgré tout de
positiver
on n'a pas trouvé
mais je suis content qu'ils
entreprennent cette démarche là c'est
fermé une piste ça c'est important aussi
aujourd'hui le problème de Jonathan
c'est que 15 ans après la disparition de
Cécile le dossier est sous la menace
d'une fermeture définitive une
conclusion qui serait insupportable pour
lui pour moi cette affaire et d'une
extrême importance la disparition de CC
c'est pas que un dossier
trouve que c'est un devoir de ne pas
laisser la disparition de ces cils comme
un énigme à perpétuité
est-ce que c'est l'entêtement est-ce que
c'est la conviction
[Musique]
sans doute les deux
Eric Mouzin le dossier sur la
disparition d'Estelle n'a jamais été
menacé jusqu'à aujourd'hui de clôture
c'est quelque chose que vous redoutez ça
alors la décision de de clôturer un
dossier
relève de l'initiative du juge
d'instruction
pour l'instant ça n'est pas d'actualité
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il reste
ouvert jusqu'à éventuel résolution
alors si j'adhère aux propos de Nicolas
Sarkozy quand il était misé à
l'intérieur il m'avait dit que jamais ce
dossier ne se clôturé donc je suis un
garçon simple je crois les engagements
des hommes politiques est-ce que les
médias ça peut être utile dans ce cas-là
oui je crois que les médias peuvent être
utiles parce qu'on voit que
régulièrement il y a des informations
qui nous sont qui sont fournies aux
enquêteurs
parce que des gens ont la mémoire
ravivée par l'évocation de ce dossier je
crois que personne dans l'enquête ne
désespère que un jour le bon témoignage
la bonne délation tombe parce que on
aura reparlé du dossier parce que
quelqu'un aura envie de parler
nous sommes en juin 2012 et un an après
ses voyages en Algérie l'élection
présidentielle française va peut-être
changer la donne
Marie-Laure voit dans l'alternance
politique un espoir
elle contacte alors son député le
socialisme Jean-Louis Bianco voilà je
vous rends sollicite parce qu'il y a eu
un changement quand même important en
France qui je pense peut jouer entre
favor en Algérie je suis bien entendu
prêt à
intervenir je pense que vous soyez sur
l'Elysée comme vous l'avez été dans le
passé et puis c'est bien mettre au
courant prendre contact avec les
nouveaux interlocuteurs aussi parce que
en fait c'est comme si on repartait à
zéro alors que ça fait deux ans qu'on a
exactement et du côté du côté algérien
il faut essayer de nouveau de frapper à
la porte le plus haut possible
c'est-à-dire le président de la
République l'homologue de notre
président de la République
ce que j'attends c'est une intervention
de la France pour qu'on me reconnaisse
mes droits écoute au moins je puisse
voir mes enfants j'y crois encore j'y
crois encore parce que j'ai envie que
mes enfants reviennent et que j'arrête
d'y croire il reviendront pas comme ça
je veux croire qu'on doit y arriver je
suis pas du tout en train de dire qu'on
va y arriver j'en sais rien mais je
crois qu'on doit y arriver c'est pas
c'est pas possible qu'on n'arrive pas
malgré les différences d'approche des
systèmes judiciaires
a donné une solution humaine à un drame
donc moi je veux vraiment y croire et je
me battre merci
toujours présent pourtant malgré cet
engagement Marie-Laure reste lucide à
présent c'est du concret qu'elle attend
[Musique]
pour Jonathan aussi 2012 est une année
cruciale
l'affaire Cécile Vallin est sous la
menace d'un classement une hypothèse que
Jonathan refuse d'envisager pas plus que
Chloé la grande sœur de Cécile le 8 juin
2012 à la date anniversaire de la
disparition de Cécile ils ont
rendez-vous avec leur avocate en région
parisienne
cela fait 8 ans que Cathy Richard suit
la faire ce jour-là quand elle les
reçoit elle vient de plaider à Chambéry
pour la non fermeture du dossier de
Cécile c'est une injustice selon elle
c'est certains qu'on est plus dans le
cadre d'une enquête en flagrance ou dans
un cadre d'enquête à chaud même à tiède
on est on est dans une enquête vraiment
on est vraiment dans un col case mais en
France c'est pas possible le Cold Case
c'est à dire que en France on veut pas
faire comme à la télé reprendre le
dossier dit à 20 ans d'y à 30 ans et
imaginez les gens tant de temps après en
France si le dossier bouclé aujourd'hui
dans 10 ans c'est fini
autrement dit si le dossier est fermé
c'est comme si la justice jetait
l'éponge mais grâce à un nouvel élément
que nous ne dévoilerons pas pour ne pas
gêner la procédure en cours l'avocate a
obtenu que le juge d'instruction ne
boucle pas la faire ça veut dire que
quelque part quelqu'un c'est et que
quelque part quelqu'un peut mettre fin à
la torture de Jonathan de Chloé une
petite victoire dans un dossier qui
cumule les désillusions
c'est ça le grand soulagement c'est pas
la joie puisque on ne sait toujours pas
ce qui s'est passé mais c'est le minimum
pour inviter un impair de
justice
disons que je n'arrive pas à partager le
soulagement
à la limite j'ai envie de dire presque
ce qui s'est passé ça a moins
d'importance pour moi ce qui est
important c'est surtout de de
savoir et comme je sais qu'il y a au
moins une personne qui sait
j'ai besoin de de nous on a besoin de
trouver le corps même si quelqu'un
disait nous donner juste un indice
anonyme nous disant ben voilà
aller chercher là et que on trouve un
corps et qu'on l'identifie et que c'est
Cécile mais pour moi là je serai
soulagée voilà là je serai soulagée
ça fait déjà 15 ans que je vis sans
Cécile je ne suis pas en attente d'un
coup de fil pour m'annoncer
son retour l'espoir c'est surtout savoir
ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi entend-t-on souvent les parents
d'enfants disparus dire qu'il serait
soulagé d'apprendre qu'ils sont morts
je crois qu'il y a deux raisons d'abord
il est impossible de faire le deuil d'un
enfant en vie
l'esprit continue de travailler l'espoir
continue de d'exister et la partie bien
sûr consciente et raisonnable de notre
psychisme nous dit que cet espoir est
vain mais tant qu'on nous apprend pas
que c'est fini nous continuons d'espérer
quand l'enfant disparaît que le parent
ne sait pas ce qu'il est devenu c'est
encore plus compliqué c'est réellement
renoncer à l'espoir sans y renoncer
vraiment l'espoir insensé avec en plus
les études maintenant de de
morphopsychologie on arrive à
reconstituer ce que pourrait être le
visage de cet enfant s'il vivait ce qui
entretient l'espoir illusoire que cet
enfant pourrait revenir la seconde
raison c'est que l'imagination va
toujours plus loin que la réalité et
donc il est littéralement
cauchemardesque pour ses parents
lorsqu'il pense à la mort probable de
leur enfant d'imaginer les conditions
peut-être atroces dans lesquelles cet
enfant est disparu
savoir permet de limiter l'imagination
permet de brider l'imagination on a des
certitudes elles sont atroces mais au
moins elles sont finies elles sont
déterminées elles ne changeront plus et
on peut commencer à ne pas oublier mais
à surmonter le trauma
Oliver
c'est savoir ce qu'est devenu sa fille
Cécile voilà la clé pour peut-être enfin
commencer à cicatriser
c'est
comme une
plaie qui ne se guérit pas complètement
le deuil est impossible
pour moi
puisque je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé
je suis motivé
100 fois plus par l'amour ceci pour
la
le désir de vengeance ou de
mais c'est vrai que pendant un moment au
départ
j'aurais volontiers
dans le ventre
la personne qui est responsable de sa
disparition
mais bon tout ça tous ces sentiments
très violents sont balayés depuis
ça
[Musique]
vous finissez votre livre avec ces mots
à titre personnel je suis fière de
n'avoir jamais renié mes convictions sur
la peine de mort dont je reste un
farouche opposant oui là je crois que
ça ne change rien je pense avoir des
convictions d'humanisme et je ne
changera pas et la peine de mort c'est
certainement la chose la plus absurde la
plus
aberrante qui existe
et il a vraiment été démontré que que ça
ne servait à rien que ça n'apportait
rien si vous étiez vraiment la réponse
de la barbarie par la barbarie donc je
remettrai jamais sans cause
Jonathan
Marie-Laure
deux parents qui ne se connaissent pas
de parents dont la vie tourne
aujourd'hui autour d'un seul mot
espoir ce qui est important pour moi
c'est que moi je dis des mots d'amour à
ces cils tous les jours
tous les jours
voilà je peux pas
je peux pas m'effondrer je sais pas j'ai
je m'effondre et je remonte et je me dis
ils vont revenir ils vont revenir je
vais le revoir et il faut qu'il retrouve
leur chambre leur école leur maman et je
suis persuadée de ça il y a pas d'autres
solutions en fait que que d'espérer de
tout faire pour qu'il revienne